first ball dry tag Italian salted water  these long thin ribbons of pasta come  curled up in less and take around 10  minutes to cook  then add olive oil to hot pan a fry  finely chopped onion thinly slice garlic  and sweat until soft  next remove the meat from your sausages  by cutting open their skins and crumble  into the pan  Fennell or Sicilian sausages are perfect  for this dish but any flavored sausage  will do  when the meat is browned add half cherry  tomatoes season  and add a few spoonfuls of the pasta  cooking water as a starch thickens the  sauce and helps it stick to the pasta  drain the Tecla telly and add to the  sausage meat sauce  finish with freshly grated Parmesan  perfect when you're really busy but  still want great tasting food fast  my amazing tagliatelle with quick  sausage meat bolognaise spooning creme  fraiche  and dot with lumps of creamy ricotta  cheese finish that with a nice ball of  creme fraiche let that sit there